all right let's uh let's talk about some
stuff many of you sent me clips of this
sort of coming out party interview that
former democratic congresswoman Tulsi
gabbard did on The Joe Rogan uh program
and it's it's really pretty bad
um one of the things that was just bad
about it is this cat litter box story
again rears its ugly head this is a
story that has been repeated so many
times now about a teacher who installed
a litter box for a student who
identifies as a cat and it's like are we
we're still telling this debunked story
listen to this there's kids ready for
this
my friend his wife is a school teacher
and
she works at a school that had to
install a litter box in the girls room
because there is a girl who's a furry
who identifies as an animal and her
mother
badgered the school
until they agreed to put a litter box in
one of the Stalls so this girl goes into
the litter room or to the The Girls Room
the litter room that's genius and
urinates or whatever I don't know if she
poops in it that's pretty gross yeah I
mean like if you could teach your cat by
the way here's the thing if you could
teach your cat to use the toilet you
would okay yeah like you don't want a
box of piss in your house it's the word
I've had cats my whole life it's the
worst thing about having cats you got to
clean that box of piss every day yeah
like it's the greatest thing about dogs
all right
um I again it's always like this friend
that friend okay what school exactly is
this happening at because it's already
been debunked multiple times uh Nebraska
lawmaker apologizes for debunked litter
box claim a Nebraska state law Banker
apologized after he publicly cited a
persistent but debunked rumor alleging
that schools are putting litter boxes
and bathrooms to accommodate children
who self-identify as cats that was
Senator Bruce bostelman
um that's from March there's another one
of these stories Reuters fact check
Michigan school district did not Place
litter boxes in student restrooms this
was from January social media users are
sharing a video of a Midland Public
School Board of Education meeting where
a Community member says litter boxes are
in bathrooms for students who identify
as furries and that's also not true how
could anyone really still believe this
at this point then they get into a
conversation about DeSantis and you know
the the sort of slippery thing about
Tulsi is everything is always couched
sort of like we gotta escape the
two-party system the duopoly it's not
working yeah almost all of us agree with
that but then to come to something like
well the santis is the most reasonable
in that context that doesn't really make
any sense I think if they had someone
like Ron DeSantis who seems to be like
the most reasonable amongst the
potential candidates he seems to be you
know a pretty no-nonsense guy not
without his flaws but it he's more
reasonable than anything that I'm seeing
on the left what
what is there anything you see on the
left look at I mean listen just in a
sort of totally banal and milk toast way
how is DeSantis more reasonable than
just like
Josh Shapiro in Pennsylvania I mean it's
he's he's too reasonable it's chew on
two milk toast uh you gotta vote for him
over mastriano because he's he's so
reasonable there's just nothing
controversial
DeSantis yeah at least with his the way
he handled covid yeah you know it's just
it's one of those things where
as it's all playing out there's this
sense of hopelessness because there's
not a like a clearly defined path where
this country's ship gets righted it's
like I I just see a lot of chaos and and
a lot of confusion and a lot of
infighting and I don't know how this
plays out and this is the tricky thing
about these conversations which is it
they they don't wrongly identify certain
issues the infighting is insane the
division is insane but it's insane
because there's one side that has gone
insane making demonstrably false claims
about everything about
um the 2020 election about vaccines
about trans people about foreign policy
about it so then the and so DeSantis
what
doesn't it doesn't seem like there's a
real clear oh this is our path to sanity
uh you're right and I think the first
step towards that path though is people
recognizing
what the insanity is right and they're
not if you listen to Tulsi because she's
telling you the insanity is woke elitism
of a cabal an anti-white racism and uh
who else knows I don't even remember
what else she said in that wacky video
on Tuesday
and um and and the problems
um and I think that more and more of
these things these things are coming to
light
um I can tell you I mean I know there
are a lot of Democrats that feel the
same kind of frustration that I feel
with the Democratic party leadership
quietly yes yeah there's a lot of quiet
disagreement where people are just like
I'm not voting for Trump but right what
the [ __ ] are we doing right and and I
think there's there's uh there's that in
the in the Republican party as well yeah
and so I think that that creates yeah so
quite literally now the epitome of the
enlightened Centrist and then just
lastly on this talking about
um the Russian invasion of Ukraine and
well let's just watch this first and
then discuss with things like funding
the Ukraine war with Russia please
explain to people what that means and
why why we're sending so much money over
to Ukraine
so so let's start with with that let's
start with the military industrial
complex what is it who is it it is these
massive defense corporations who make uh
all these different weapon systems from
the smallest to the most powerful
nuclear weapons and missiles so Tulsi
goes down the road of military
industrial complex now there's no
greater critic of the
military-industrial complex than me but
what you have to understand here is that
this isn't really the issue when it
comes specifically to Ukraine you could
have a general conversation and say
should we be doing foreign aid should we
be doing foreign aid with weaponry
if so what types of countries should we
support or not but the focus now when
it's like listen the ukrainians are the
victims of an act of aggression by Putin
and they are trying to defend their
country and that's why with Ukraine we
are sending stuff that we already have
and other countries are doing the same
but to make it all of a sudden about the
military industrial complex now with
Ukraine really misses the point of that
particular engagement and again it's not
about oh Tulsi is a Russian agent or
whatever no it's not about that it's
this is exactly the ideology that plays
right into Putin's hands which is he's
the guy doing the war of aggression and
the focus becomes why are we sending
anything to Ukraine even though it's
pennies it's it's a drop in the bucket
what is being sent to Ukraine and they
are genuinely trying to defend
themselves so all the normal stuff from
Tool C on the Rogan program and it is
very disappointing one more kind of
Tulsi related thing thing
um congresswoman Alexandria
ocasio-cortez held a town hall recently
and it got invaded by you know I don't
want to you I know some people call them
the Tulsi stands some call them the tool
cells I don't know who they are they're
people who just seem obsessed with Tulsi
gabbard and they exploded during an AOC
Town Hall take a look at this
there's a nuclear war which you voted to
send arms and weapons to Ukraine Colby
gathered she's left the Democratic party
okay you originally voted you ran as an
outsider yet you've been voting to start
this war in Ukraine she voted to start a
war in Ukraine I mean what are you
talking about
[Music]
[Applause]
there will be no neighbors if there's a
nuclear bomb so now a second guy pops up
you voted to mobilize and send money to
Ukrainian Nazis now the entire Ukrainian
Nazis thing are there some Nazis in
Ukraine yes there are Nazis in the U.S
as well there's a lot of not the the US
military has quite a problem with
right-wing extremism
um but saying that what we're doing is
supporting Nazis by
slightly helping Ukraine to defend
itself against this invasion of
aggression from Russia you're really
missing the boat
he's telling the right truth you have
done nothing Tulsi gabbard has shown
guts it's almost like they're paid
people but I'm not I'm not saying they
are but it's so outrageous you would say
nobody could really believe this you
must be getting paid
[Music]
listen there are many Fair criticisms of
Alexandria ocasio-cortez but you're a
warmonger
I don't know that that's really the
right critique for AOC and again
when when you only have a hammer
everything looks like a nail when you're
obsessed with the cult of personality
around Tulsi gabbard
anybody with a different view is wrong
and if it's a war Monger or whatever it
is you assign them that label and that's
what we're seeing here and it's quite
sad real quick a [ __ ] this is just like
a small little side thing but I found it
interesting Fox News host Jesse Waters
was confused by the existence of
Hispanic and Latin American Jews and he
genuinely is visibly confused it's it's
you know
it would be as if these people knew
something about anything it's in there
and he totally blows it because he was
in a hearing you remember Ted Cruz asked
him and you guys got weeks to prepare
for the hearing that's all they do is
prepare for hearings and he goes you
have any people that cross the border no
Germany no kids that are in your cages
now do you even know if Joe Biden or
Kamala Harris went to the Border in 2021
no he couldn't answer he couldn't answer
anything now he was probably nominated
at least that's the what they touted
because he was Hispanic he was born in
Cuba his parents are Jewish which was
confusing to me but you know I don't
know a lot about about that stuff yeah
no we can tell you don't know much about
that and again it just this is not like
that exotic or bizarre of a thing
um there are plenty of Jews in Central
and South America I'm Jewish I'm from
Argentina plenty of Jews in Argentina
Jews have lived in Cuba for a very long
time there are some Cubans who actually
their Jewish ancestry goes goes back to
there's a weird term but crypto Jews
Jews who were fleeing the Spanish
Inquisition and lived as non-jews but
were actually Jewish and
um there's been Jewish immigration to
Cuba
um you know between 1900 and 1950 and
many many countries in Latin America
with not insignificant Jewish
populations Argentina at the top of the
list with about 180 000 Jews as of eight
years ago these numbers have changed
Brazil has close to a hundred thousand
Jews Mexico 40 000 etc etc this is you
know it would be nice if I'm not saying
this is the standard by which we judge
whether people know anything
I don't know much about Jews in Latin
America but it would be nice if just the
reality of the world weren't so
confusing to Fox News hosts and to these
right Wingers who are so confident in
their opinions about everything but they
just know so little about everything as
well disappointing I think maybe is the
term I would apply let me know your
thoughts find me on Twitter at dpacman
quick break great Friday show for you
today
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David packman show is of course a
community supported program you are part
of that community and I would love for
you to sign up and show your support
pledge your support at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code uh big
voting 22 a reminder about how important
what we have coming up in early November
is voting yes and of course you'll get
all the member benefits no matter what
discount you get including the daily
bonus show commercial free audio and
video streams of the Show members only
Town Hall events and many many other
things let's hear from some people in
the audience through Discord you can
find our Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord let's start today with Nevin in
Tennessee Nevin welcome to the show
what's on your mind today
uh hey David I just wanted to ask about
what your opinion is on the
Revolutionary left and a lot of people
revolutionary left I found have for some
reason support China and Russia and the
Ukrainian Invasion so I just want to
know your thoughts on that yeah you know
I think one of the things about the
Revolutionary left is there they claim
to be against imperialism and
colonialism when it's the United States
and do not apply the same standards to
other countries now of course
sometimes circumstances are different in
other countries than in the United
States if you take a country without a
colonial history that's tiny with a
small economy or whatever it would be
logical to think about the country
differently than the United States but
there are certain principles that to me
are of Paramount importance I'm against
authoritarianism I'm against
um uh theocracy I may get you know all
these different things so when I see
authoritarianism in China or in
Venezuela or wherever
I'm against that because that's an
important principle to me and I would
like to see these so-called
revolutionary leftists maybe apply those
standards uniformly
okay thanks for answering my question
congrats to 1.5 million subscribers by
the way thank you and we are heading on
to 2 million that's the new that's the
new goal and I hope that we we get there
soon
yeah thank you all right good now Nevin
not super excited about 2 million but
that's okay we're gonna we're gonna work
towards it's gonna be a great thing
let's go next to win from Indiana win
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hey David how are you doing I'm doing
well
I still have a I have an exam in like
three hours in uh regulatory economics
um so I have a question on monopolies
okay so what are your views on like
um not really regulating monopolies
because what I've learned and like from
Game Theory and such uh some monopolies
are actually good where it can compete
with bigger firms I'm kind of
paraphrasing but I'm not sure how to
articulate it well well so here's the
thing the problem with Monopoly power is
that it be becomes so you've got it
first you've got it back up and you have
to say what are our principles here if
you claim to be about allowing markets
to direct resources right like if you're
a supplant supply and demand guy for
lack of a better term you have to
recognize that a monopoly
is getting out of pure supply and demand
because the Monopoly can get a
Stranglehold on an industry to the point
where normal Market forces no longer
apply either because of barriers to
entry or the Dynamics of market share or
for other reasons so if you claim to
care about markets directing resources
and supply and demand
then it follows that you have to be
against most monopolies now there can be
Exceptions there could be areas of
society where for example I as a Social
Democrat think that in certain areas we
don't want markets to direct resources
so I've talked about Healthcare I've
talked about public education and some
others you might decide that there's
certain areas where Monopoly power is
actually okay or good either for
regulatory reasons or whatever but
the first question is what is your view
on markets directing resources that has
to be answered first before you can
answer the question about Monopoly power
so what I'm getting at is like social
efficiency
so for example in the event where
there's like uh let's say Walmart right
or whatever it's it's like a big big
retail company and there are like the
let's say there's Walmart and there's
other three small retail companies
um Walmart is like the dominant like
they have the majority market share yes
is do you think it's okay if you allow
the two smaller Industries I mean two
smaller companies to merge in order to
compete with Walmart because you know
what Walmart is dominating a market
share now if the government allows the
two other companies to come to emerge
that would be competitive to Walmart
which reduces Walmart's market share
therefore it creates a better
competition that's kind of what I'm
getting it still has the Lion's Share of
the market share even after the merger
of the two smaller players the Monopoly
issue really isn't with the merger of
the two smaller players it's with
Walmart and you've still got an
oligopoly primarily controlled by one
player so you're absolutely correct I
don't think it actually
is a tough one because the merger of the
two smaller companies doesn't change the
Dynamics of Walmart as the Monopoly or
the near Monopoly
but it could become a duopoly right yes
it could absolutely
and would you be in favor of that if
because you are you are a Social
Democrat and you believe in markets
depends on the industry depends on the
specific it's such a specific question
you've really got to look at the
particulars of the situation very hard
to answer in the in the abstract
gotcha gotcha
yeah so like yeah I'm actually like
looking into it like according to like
looking at the market share and like the
math behind it like the whether if these
two companies merge is it really going
to create social efficiency which means
like is it going to give more options to
Consumers if you know I'm getting at
because that is a very important
question to be asking and also does it
benefit consumers many of these Telecom
mergers when you ask that question you
say well actually it's not really going
to be good for consumers in any way
it'll probably just lead to higher
prices and worse customer service
hmm yeah yeah there's some good luck on
the exam my friend oh thank you so much
all right there is win from Indiana very
very important question let's go next to
Chris from Austin Texas Chris from
Austin uh what's on your mind today
Chris from Austin Texas you are unmuted
uh but we can't hear you which probably
means you have the wrong audio device
selected in Discord Chris from Austin
Texas go ahead
and last chance for Chris from Austin
Texas whose audio is not working
and there it is Chris from Austin Texas
with a technical issue let's go to bite
from Deltona bite welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
hey thanks David
um I just want to start by saying that
um I am sort of a fellow bi-cultural uh
Denizen of the world I was uh have split
time
um from the time I was 0 to 18 between
Peru and the United States and uh the
reason I mentioned that I think it's
important because when you do get your
education outside of the United States
of course you kind of you know pull
yourself out of the indoctrination
stream
um you know the cultural
um you know indoctrination and social
conditioning that takes place if you
experience the American educational
system from you know you know
kindergarten through high school
um so I just kind of want to throw that
out I wanted to get your take on an idea
that I had based on a letter that I
received from Marco Rubio with regards
to abortion okay
um the thing that he States in his
letter is uh that he is defending the
rights of the 65 million unborn children
that did not get to experience the dream
the American dream because of the during
the 50 years right they were never born
in other words right right so he's
defending their rights now I had a
thought about possibly painting them
into a corner uh because technically
speaking you know from their position my
understanding would be that they are
they are defending the rights of the
fetus to be born yeah and here's the
thing I think it's important to mention
they would say that it's a person
already and that's why it has rights
right so exactly but here's where I'm
going with this yes now when we're born
of course we have a federal social
security number which basically
establishes IR uh our identity I
personally think that we should be able
to legally argue in court that if the
states are going to defend the fetus
they would be required to give that
fetus and identification number and at
that point in time also of course uh
State all the benefits that that fetus
is going to be uh uh and the host is
going to receive on the basis of that uh
uh establishment of identity got it yes
I'm one step ahead of you on this I've
got a number of different clips you can
find in which I point out this hypocrisy
if you're talking about a person at
conception uh should have a Social
Security number should qualify for child
support
should prevent
um a month if if the pregnant mother is
an undocumented immigrant she shouldn't
be able to be deported because it's
already a person and it's here in the
United States there's a whole list of
these your uh the concept is absolutely
right and I've elaborated on it before
okay so you said that do you agree with
that that would that would paint them
into a corner as well no I mean they'll
come up with they'll come up with some
way out of it but I agree with you that
it exposes a hypocrisy for sure
okay all right cool well thanks for uh
your comment on that and sorry I missed
that before but started started
listening to you you know right uh
around uh the the 2016 election or right
before that I appreciate it very much
thank you for the call
all right take it easy all right you too
uh yeah that's that's very very uh
astute observation for sure there uh
okay remember that if you'd like to get
on your nickname in the waiting Lobby on
Discord needs to be name and location of
where you're calling from it doesn't
even have to be real but it has to be
name and location otherwise you are not
going to be eligible to participate
today let's go to Carl from Bremerton
Carl welcome what's on your mind today
ah how's it going David so
pretty much what I wanted to say was
um should I feel like I shouldn't be but
should I be celebrating the like win of
Tim Ryan against JD Vance in the line of
the year and it's getting a lot of
traction and whatnot even though I find
him much less liberal than I like but I
understand it's because he's in Ohio
yeah and he has to kind of walk that
weird line where he's got to get the
indecisive Trump voters but also let me
address that what was the line of the
year I watched the debate what was the
line of the Year oh it was the the we
need a ass kicker not an ass kisser like
yes
it was a good line like I I remember
being like wow like I was watching it
when you watch it and I reacted the same
way I I like Tim Ryan as a person he's
been on the show and I've had a couple
conversations with him off air like
before we we did an interview
um I to be honest I don't know Tim
Ryan's real politics and what I mean by
that is
at one point he seemed quite a bit more
Progressive to me than the way he's
running right now I understand the
Dynamics of Ohio may impact how he's
running he's been critical on issues
related to the border of Kamala Harris
and Biden and all these other things
um I think that
as a practical matter JD Vance is such a
dangerous disaster that like you just
got to vote for Tim Ryan if you live in
Ohio it's obviously the right decision
but without a doubt the way he's running
now it's well to my right that's for
damn sure
um yeah and that's pretty much how I
felt was like Hey this I'm glad that
this is like because this seems like I
feel like if I was an indecisive like
voter that was like maybe thinking of
voting for Trump if I saw that yeah and
actually looked into it they'd be like
wow he is like awful I should definitely
vote for that guy but for me I'm from
Washington right so like I'm pretty
liberal anyway so when I see that and
then I hear him talking about how he
agreed with Trump I'm like yeah I don't
think
yo I don't think that's something I
would be like happy about no like then
I'm like you know he is in Ohio so I get
it yeah that's why I'm struggling with
what to do
overwhelmingly the better option and
also if he was a presidential candidate
I'd say you sound almost like a
Republican
yeah 100 yeah all right Carl thank you
for the call appreciate it thank you man
I appreciate it all right that's a big
race so I hope all of our Ohio voters
will indeed be uh voting in that one it
is extremely extremely important uh
let's go next to Lucian from England
Lucian welcome to the show what's on
your mind
yes I can
ah there we go
um thanks for picking um first of all
how much are you keeping up with the
economic and political situation in the
UK what's a general take on it only a
little bit I if I understand correctly
it seems there are significant economic
concerns in the UK Liz truss initially
planned a tax cut for the rich which
correct me if I'm wrong she is since
abandoned because in the context of
what's going on it seemed like a
disastrously bad idea
yes that's right yeah and then I saw an
economic prediction that the UK could
have some serious hurt in front of it as
well uh no I don't know that I have any
particular opinion I mean I think the um
I I when I read the headlines about
specifically what's predicted in the UK
economically I wonder whether it's
really just going to be part of a bigger
economic shift in the U.S and Western
Europe like I'm not fully understanding
why this would be isolated to the UK
but after I was going to ask as to what
extent some of the same issues present
in the USA as well
absolutely I mean our economies are so
tied together and dependent among upon
many of the same industry Industries
many of the same trade relationships
obviously our stock markets don't move
in lockstep necessarily but it seems
strange to see some sky's falling
predictions for the UK and then some
predictions in the U.S that after
December 2023 should actually look
pretty good it seems hard to imagine
that there would be such a stark
difference
we'll see what happens I think the the
interest rate question is probably the
most pressing right now
um it's pretty dire here I'd say in
terms of interest rates I'd say me and
my partner just bought a house two or
three months ago we managed to complete
that if we were to have done it now
instead we would be paying 50 more per
month on our mortgage basically what are
mortgage rates in the UK
um when we got it was about two and a
half percent I believe now it's gone up
to six percent oh so similarly similar
to here yeah
yeah that's a big difference a good
thing you bought when you did I guess
very very lucky just another really
really quick question you said you've
got some Heritage from Eastern Europe
right oh yeah yeah I mean almost
exclusively
have you have you actually been there no
I have not
if you uh if you'd be interested I'd be
quite curious to know what you think
about the culture and everything I'm
from there initially yeah I mean so one
of the things is my family being all
Jews from Eastern Europe
they you know spoke a different language
and sort of were were relatively uh
concentrated in certain communities due
to some unfortunate realities at the
time
um and so you know I think that by by
and large the culture in which my
ancestors lived
primarily have sort of eroded in Eastern
Europe in you know Ukraine and Russia
and Belarus so I don't even know that I
could really I could go and see what the
culture is like now I don't think I
would have the experience of seeing what
was the culture that my ancestors lived
in because it's mostly gone
right I understand that that's really
really unfortunate yeah all right thank
you very much the call thank you
thank you all right let's take a very
quick break if you're holding don't hang
up because we're going right back to the
phones in a moment
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show Let's uh
get back to Discord davidpackman.com
Discord we are taking calls for the week
and seeing what's on people's minds
let's go
um why don't we go next to Derek from
Orange County Derek what's going on
hi David I had a quick question about
um generally how you see the Maga GOP
and feel free to reframe the question if
it's a little too convoluted for you
okay
um I just wanted to ask how you see this
current iteration of the Maga GOP do you
see it as a logical conclusion of the
modern GOP as though they're leaving
behind folks like Romney Liz Cheney were
were their politics like a necessary
conclusion to our logical conclusion to
what we're seeing now with the current
manga GOP listen I don't know about
logical conclusion but there is a
Continuum and I talked about this
earlier in the week where this all go
the the modern Maga GOP
is the conclusion let's wait on logical
but it's the conclusion to
Civil Rights era starts upsetting 1950s
conservatives who feel as though uh
minorities are starting to get too many
rights and too entitled or whatever
leads to Reagan
uh and anti-welfare sentiment and some
kind of like meme politics leads to the
Gingrich takeover as Speaker of the
House in 94 and radicalization of the
party
Clinton derangement syndrome during the
kenstar Lewinsky investigation
dum dum George W bush that ushered in
kind of just a lot of non-thinking
people into the party
Obama which coalesced a bunch of racists
into the party and conspiracy theorists
and then Trump was sort of like the
final layer so far like there will be
more layers as time goes forward so
whether it's logical I don't know but
it's been a steady 50-year decline so in
that sense it's not completely
unpredictable I guess I would say
yeah I mean I'm pretty pretty kind of
new to in terms of like paying attention
to politics I would say ever since I
guess Trump but I feel like for some
reason when the sentiment of like not
really accepting election results
doesn't feel too new to me but it's
definitely a lot more prevalent in this
current political climate right now
absolutely I don't know if you agree
with that yeah I agree with that I
completely agree with that yeah it's
become you know it's the overt nature
and Brazen nature of if we win it was
fair but if we lost it was rigged that
is that that feels new and different
yeah yeah for sure yeah well thank you
so much for taking my call I really
appreciate you summarizing that very
clearly for me I appreciate the
opportunity to do so very much thank you
for the call let's keep going I mean the
the calls have really been quite good
today we don't want to uh depart from
that if you can imagine that would be
sad let's go to mark from Los Angeles
California Mark what's going on keep us
going here
hey David
hi you hear me yes okay yeah
um question uh first of all I just
wanted to know do you think that Mike
Lindell
um
has the remember you just got described
as sort of um persistent delusion that
is focused
Oh California
yeah because it was just watching that
interview first of all it was exhausting
congratulations to being able to survive
it because I mean after a certain point
of his he's so relentless you just want
to start yelling at it I know because
you just can't he doesn't one of the
things is terrible about talking to him
is that he doesn't really listen to you
and and try to process what you're
saying correct and and try to come back
with a a cogent answer that actually
pertains to what you said he just has
this Gish Gallop of of of things to say
and and it once you try to once you
knock something down
he denies that but not fully and yes
moves on to something else
yeah and it's just like I was just like
you need help or or maybe someone needs
to interview him who literally is just
as rude as he is right no it's difficult
and I got both positive and negative
feedback about how I handled the
interview and the thing is you have to
kind of think about other ways to handle
it I could interrupt a lot more but I
already got some criticism for
interrupting too much I could not
interrupt at all in which case we would
have one Gish Gallop for 30 minutes and
then we don't go absolutely anywhere
else
um you know you can always make the
argument that I could have been more
prepared and you can always be more
prepared but the problem is he can
always find some small fire to set with
something I haven't heard of no matter
how much prep I do so it is really
difficult to handle those interviews
yeah it's kind of reminiscent of what
Bill Maher was saying why he wouldn't
was it Bill Maher Sam Harris Sam Harris
Sam Harris exactly oh you know exactly
wow like like telekinetics
exactly what I'm saying what uh what Sam
Harris is saying why he won't have on
anti-vaxxers right because he's just you
know they can always say we're going to
end up study from kathmandu's Regional
Hospital you know it's like I don't know
I didn't see that does it I don't know
what that is oh that's a win right right
absolutely yeah yeah yeah uh and Mark
are you are you originally from like New
York or Long Island
I'm originally from Washington DC oh
interesting Oh I thought I heard a
little a little bit of a New York accent
there no
no
no
no
no
Washington DC born and raised Warren
Howard University Hospital went to
Howard University beautiful
um yeah
um and then the other thing I wanted to
say is um uh I was watching one of your
live feeds and you were playing some
voicemail
and um there was a there was a black
gentleman who was was discussing how
um
Herschel Walker fills in certain uh very
negative stereotypes about black people
and you want to play it too long because
it got it got a little dark I was
worried about mod like terms and
conditions having an issue on like some
of the platforms we were on like I know
the party was making but it could be the
type of thing that we get dinged for
okay I see I see because I was thinking
like I was actually watching MSNBC and
uh the one of the shows on there with uh
hosted by um I forget her name it's a
black woman but uh but she um one of the
her guests actually made a really great
comment about the fact that Herschel
Walker is an insult to Black excellence
and and the the he fulfills many of the
stereotypes that white people have about
about black men he literally is a
walking and bottoming of almost every
single concept right that black men have
been strapped with since slavery you
know so um and that's one it's funny
enough you are you familiar with Rashad
Rishi it's beautiful yeah yeah
he he actually tried to interview
um what's the guy's name he was he was
caught having sex with men what's his
name I have no idea I don't know the the
guy that you
you twice oh he's Jesse Peterson Jesse
Lee Peterson he didn't make it through
two two questions with Jesse Lee
Peterson I'm gonna have to check that
out because he could smell it a mile
away and if you're familiar with Aaron
Aaron Magruder's show The Boondocks he
very much embodies that um that
character that stereotype that he has on
there that sort of like you know it
gives a a visceral reaction to
African-Americans that's kind of
shocking and we immediately wanted to
shut it down immediately because it's it
kind of calls back to some things that
are very dark well just listen you
really said it all uh I appreciate the
call I hope all is well in LA
yeah absolutely absolutely and of course
I love your show keep playing the
commentary and um yeah I hope to hear
did you make did you did you see
anything about the debate that happened
um in Ohio yes we we streamed it like
Mark I gotta run because I got so many
people waiting all right my friend okay
okay thank you there's mark from LA with
the many many questions some of which
some of which I was able to answer let's
go to Terence from Delaware Terence
what's going on
hi uh David it's good to good to talk to
you
um thank you for your uh content I've
been watching you since uh around the
January 6th incident
um thank you I just have a quick
question
um so
for the average person
uh what do you think is the most
effective thing that they can do and I'm
gonna give you an example because I know
it's sort of a broad question
um so for me the most important issue is
facing Americans and humanity is climate
change and sort of uh Environmental
Protections and so I would say the most
important things are
sort of voting and then maybe putting
your uh your money towards politicians
that favor environmentalism right it's
sort of hard for me as an individual to
invest in long-term environmentalism but
I would say that's the most important
for for that particular issue so
I don't know if you have a good answer
to that question I mean these it's the
question about the meta issues which
I've talked about a little before how
our politics is financed is one of the
most important things climate and
environment as you're talking about is
one of the most important things how our
elections are managed and held which by
which we're talking about you know first
pass the post voting Etc making sure
everybody votes
um and then media coverage of political
issues those to me are the most
important for meta issues and whatever
you care about be it education or
abortion or whatever
um I think it it comes from down they
are Downstream from those four issues so
I think voting and working on those four
issues are the most important things we
can do
great thank you all right Terence from
Delaware very much appreciate the call
let's go to Aiden from the DC area Aiden
welcome to the program what's going on
hey how you doing I've been watching
your show for years probably since 2017
2018. thank you
um just kind of happened upon the
channel today and noticed that you were
live I don't really have any particular
question but
um I I work at a restaurant in DC and uh
I was actually driving around DC
um on January 6th and I'll tell you it
was like when they finally sent people
to DC from Maryland it was the most
amount of police vehicles I've ever seen
in my life oh interesting
um but I work with some
um
deniers of the 2020 election and like
even to this day like we've talked about
it all and they're just like like you
they still don't believe
that Biden won and I I guess my question
to you is at this point you know what
what can you do to deprogram people I at
this point I don't know I we recently
looked at a poll where something like uh
it was either 40 or 55 percent of
Republicans still believe that Trump is
actually the winner it's it's
dangerously delusional and honestly I'm
sort of at the ready to give up phase
where my thought process is we just need
enough voter turnout to make them
irrelevant and of course that's a lot of
voter turnout that you need but I I if
they still believe it at this point what
could we possibly show them that would
change their minds and in fact I would
put it a different way they weren't
really given any evidence to get them to
start believing this stuff so I don't
even know that evidence is what's going
to get them out of it
correct yeah I'm kind of in the same
boat
um you know my problem is there's
there's so many of them you know it's
it's easier well just ignore them and
get enough votes but we're talking about
tens of millions of people here who
believe this stuff you know if you say
it's half of the people that voted Trump
you're talking about 35 ish million
people who believe that the guy who lost
actually is the guy who won I don't what
do you do what do you it's you can't fix
education quickly I mean these are
adults they're not in the in the school
system anymore to learn critical
thinking and media literacy
um I I'm at a loss quite frankly I don't
know yeah I see I'm a server so I come
across a lot of people uh from both
sides and I I've had some pretty
aggressive
Trump supporters come in that I've had
to serve really like do they try to talk
politics with you absolutely uh how does
it come up
well uh usually it's it's some jab at
Biden though that Brandon guy you know
with our taxes excuse my language but
you know something like that and it just
kind of shove it down your throat
mentality wow and then how do you
respond
um I honestly just try to agree with
them because you know like as as lightly
as I can and just avoid the subject
because you know serving them I don't
wanna
you know offend them in any way of
people tip
um if if they don't think you're a
Democrat I have pretty well I'd guess is
that you think that that's a factor
I I do I actually do have you had not
with everybody just just I would say
more the extremists have you had
situations where a customer gleaned the
fact that you were not a Maga guy and
that your tip suffered as a result
not that I would directly say like that
it happened but um
I've never given it away that I'm not
you know for either side because she
brings it up wow
sounds complex I'll have to say
yeah I I just try to avoid confrontation
I completely agree at the same time with
with people I work with that I'm more
close to and I care about when when I
see that they believe something that's
inherently false and they're just on
this side of crazy in them you know I I
just
can't think of what to do or say to
bring them back to reality reality yeah
no if you figure it out other than I
haven't figured other than politics you
know everything's great but when it
comes to that it's just like they're in
a different land I completely agree with
you Aiden thank you for the call I
appreciate it yeah keep doing what you
do David take care how many times have
we heard stories like that from servers
at restaurants it's a quite quite a
situation
um people in transportation Uber drivers
we hear it from everybody quite frankly
all right everybody we're going to take
a quick break we will be back with more
Friday show right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get into audience emails
for the week you can email info
davidpackman.com sometimes tweets or
Facebook messages or YouTube comments
may be included
um let's just get right into it because
there's so many to get to today you know
one of the funny things that happens
every time we stream a trump rally is
people who have no idea about our
Channel or anything they'll just kind of
like come by because they're looking for
the rally and then they'll see oh here's
someone talking about it that's me and
then they'll realize I'm not saying
positive things and then they get really
mad and they will start emailing so as
you can see this one in particular
happened during a recent rally on a
Saturday and Landon wrote in and just
does an all caps we love Donald Trump
you are
and then that was the end of the email
apparently they accidentally sent it so
then they follow up and they say a bum
they meant you are a bum pack it up
loser and then a little bit later by the
end of the thing they they say I can't
wait until the Patriots cancel you and
you need to get a real job get a real
job commie
and uh this is pretty common
of course this is not a communist show
and this is a real job and and in fact I
think that lots of these folks have no
clue what is going on when it comes to
Independent Media but I always
appreciate them coming by and
contributing there you know increasing
the view count by one increasing the
comment count by a couple so thanks
Landon amonti Rhoden also during a
recent Trump rally
and said you are a stoop SOB you think
dumbass Biden is good for this country
when we are paying five dollars a gallon
under his administration five dollars
for a loaf of bread eggs are twice as
much now than when Trump was President I
could on and on about the inflation
under Biden I also live by the Mexico
USA border and I've never seen so bad as
it is now crime has doubled under Biden
and on that subject I could go on and on
I Came Upon Your show by accident and
I'm glad I did because now I can use you
to show my liberal friends just how
stupid they are when Biden is not trying
to introduce dead people he's wrecking
our country with the support of idiots
like you
well Monty I'd appreciate you sending
some of those folks to my channel we're
trying to get to 2 million subscribers
on YouTube so uh yeah send them my way I
would very much very much appreciate
that Julia wrote in about my commentary
last week about
um uh leftism masculinity and the poll
that found that young women are moving
more to the left but young men are not
and Julia said I thought about your
segment today on the young women
becoming more leftist as opposed to
young men staying where they are I agree
with you that many men simply don't
admit to others that they're on the left
and the reason could be backlash from
the right-leaning friends and family
just look at these crazy right-wing nuts
calling you gay pejoratively without any
reason solely based on political opinion
keep doing what you're doing best of
luck to you and your family yeah I think
that Julia is more or less spot on and
it more or less also Echoes the comments
that I made last week you know there's
been this sort of cartoonish
stereotype of what
masculinity is supposed to be under the
Republican party and what's really funny
about it is that Trump
has espoused that idea and so have many
of his followers
despite Trump himself not
actually being that uh in fact being
very much the opposite in many ways and
that's because the facts don't really
matter it just it doesn't really make a
difference to them
um but that is the sort of picture that
they have designed and it's not a new
picture all right I mean when we talk
about they want to go back to the to the
1950s part of what we're talking about
are those
quite rigid views in fact on uh on
gender and femininity and masculinity so
I think I think Julie is definitely on
to something here's another message a
trump missing documents a while back
when this was breaking someone on Mt I
don't know what that is speculated about
them being in ivanka's casket
the documents being in ivanka's casket
now I think what the person means is
ivana's casket Ivana Trump recently died
it was all about the same time and she
noted that it took 10 strong men to
carry the casket which supposedly
contains her ashes she was mostly joking
but the more things move along the more
it seems plausible don't they have some
ground penetrating radar they could use
to check it out listen I have heard all
of these different hypotheses about
uh Ivana was buried where she was buried
I guess at or near some golf course for
a tax deduction
um there were documents in the casket
there are burned up documents and they I
have no idea it's really not super
interesting to me there are so many
other things going on it's speculative I
don't know that we would ever really
find out if something like that was
going on my thought is I don't want to
put too much of my time into that but I
know that there are many people who have
been speculating about the details of
Ivana Trump's casket I will leave it to
them Luke wrote in and says thank you
hey David just want to say thanks for
all of your work on the show
congratulations on 1.5 million
subscribers I've been listening to your
show for about three years now and much
more engaged in politics than I was
before I started listening I used to be
sort of an apolitical independent who
thought both left and right were equally
bad ah yes we called that enlightened
centrism
uh uh okay
over the past few years I've started to
realize how the radical how radical the
right Wingers have become in the Trump
era and consider myself very
left-leaning now you certainly have had
a big influence on that change you also
have a talent for clearly communicating
ideas that is all too rare which I find
myself emulating to some degree
in my job as a teacher keep up the good
work you're making a difference here's
to 2 million subscribers you know it's
so rare that we just get like a nice
email in of that kind
that I love that and I Love featuring it
Johnny Road wrote in and says there are
multiple oh how many followers on
Twitter have you lost there are multiple
countless of reporting of users that are
reporting that they have lost tens of
thousands of followers have you lost
many or any I don't even follow these
people that never would writing an
article about it now yeah so when it the
first time that it was announced that
Elon Musk was buying Twitter
tons of uh right-wing accounts gained a
ton of followers and some left-wing
accounts lost some followers I lost some
it wasn't really clear why was it people
leaving the platform joining the
platform because of the news I guess
um then it looked like Elon Musk wasn't
going to buy Twitter now that again it's
looking like he might buy it
um there were I lost four followers on
the day of that announcement now I
gained followers every day like you go
you go back hundreds of days every day I
gain followers so losing any is weird I
don't really understand it maybe it's
that on the news of Elon buying Twitter
again a bunch of left Wingers said I'm
not going to be on a platform owned by
Elon Musk so they they quit they
canceled and deleted their account I
don't really know but it was very very
minimal at least on my end Edward wrote
in about current gas prices
and says David sir why is it that
Republicans no longer talk about gas
prices pretty obvious I just think it's
funny how Republicans only pin gas
prices on Biden when they're high to be
clear I'm in agreement with you
president doesn't control gas prices in
either direction I just find it funny
how Biden is only associated with high
gas prices in their mind love your show
Edward well Edward's wrong about one
thing
it is true that many of them are just
not talking about gas prices anymore
many are talking about them in line
Trump keeps saying they're so high and
they're going even higher and he'll use
numbers a little bit less now that gas
prices are down the other thing is over
the last few days they've actually
started to take back up and again these
very same people who have been totally
silent on it for weeks now months in
fact are now back to talking about the
gas prices it's the same Circle it's
worthless it's it's really not worth
much of our time they're going to do
their routine no matter what's going on
with gas prices uh it I say we just move
on and focus on more important things
a t Rodin and asks why
says Trump's most likely going to run
for president again
my question is why would someone enter a
race and expect to win when they know
the other side's cheating if he enters
the presidential race it is a total
admission he never believed the race was
stolen not quite
the logic here is good logic which is
if Democrats have it all rigged
why would any Republicans even bother to
run why would any Republicans even
bother to vote because Democrats are
just going to steal it the way they get
around this is they say if enough of us
vote it will overwhelm the voter fraud
and so we can still win even though
there will be some fraud that's how they
kind of close the illogical Loop of
logic that they've created they say yes
there's going to be fraud it's rigged
they're cheating but if we have a big
enough margin we'll end up winning by a
little bit after all of their cheating
is accounted for I I know it doesn't
make any sense it's completely wacky but
that's their argument that's what they
claim
info davidpackman.com get your questions
in comments requests for Corrections I'm
glad to entertain and even a little bit
of trolling not too much but a little
bit of trolling we have a great bonus
show for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com you'll get instant access
instant and then if you are not part of
that group we'll be back Monday with a
new show and a new book
foreign